[Musique]
on est où là dans mon salon j'ai vu que
la présentation des perspectives
économiques en mars de mon salon parce
que j'étais aucun ennemi non
bonjour laurence boone bonjour ni rien
vous êtes là chef économiste de l'oscd
eux c'est cet organisme qui conseille
les dirigeants des des pays développés
pendant cette crise sans précédent va en
parler bien sûr c'est aussi cet
organisme qui a mis en oeuvre le plan
marshall après guerre avant de parler de
cette crise expliquez-nous votre rôle
précisément quand vous travaillez
concrètement aujourd'hui alors que le cd
vous avez vous avez maison a mis en
place le plan marshall et puis a évolué
en fait pour faire de conseil en
politique économique auprès de ses pays
membres qui sont moins qu'ils sont plus
de près de 40 aujourd'hui notre rôle
mais c'est dû rassembler des données de
placement harmonisé de faire d un ami
sur ce qu'elle veut dire sur la
situation économique sociale mais aussi
la santé l'agriculture le commerce ocde
c'est très très diverses est un peu
comme un gouvernement et ensuite
d'extraire en fait les meilleures
pratiques les meilleures politiques
économiques qui sont mises en place dans
chacun des pays pour en faire partager
l'ensemble des gouvernements alors on va
parler cette crise un le coup porté à
l'économie par ce virus il est
absolument colossal lui pour cent de
récession rien que pour la france et les
experts disent que ça sera sans doute
beaucoup plus est-ce qu'on peut
maintenant mesurer l'ampleur de cette
crise est ce qu'on peut dire jusqu'où
l'économie va s'effondrer ce qu'on peut
mesurer aujourd'hui est à peu près en
temps réel bien qu imparfaitement c'est
le choc sur l'activité économique qu
impose le confinement et donc sur la
production et sur la consommation il est
très important donc on a deux moyens de
faire ça le premier c'est de regarder
secteur par secteur de production ce qui
marche et ce qui ne marche pas et quand
on regarde ses ouailles
quand même très important puisque et met
à l'arrêt en fait à peu près un quart de
l'activité économique de notre hui on
peut aussi regarder ça de côté de la
consommation ou même moi aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas acheter tout ce qu'on achète
normalement c'est très bon et quand on
regarde de ce côté là c'est + 35 % de
notre consommation qui en fait affecté
par ça et après pour avoir l'ampleur de
ce que ça veut dire sur l'année de
croissance par exemple en termes de
récession en fait on est obligé de faire
des hypothèses sur le temps qu'on va
passer en confinement ou certains
secteurs vont rester en copinant
concrètement ça veut dire que des
milliers même des centaines de milliers
de personnes vont se retrouver au
chômage c'est ça alors il ya quelque
chose qui est très frappant elle dans
cette crise est qui et qui est
encourageant c'est que la plupart des
pays ont mis en place tout un système de
soutien à la fois aux personnes et aux
entreprises pour faire que ce choc qui
conte respectifs horaires en fait on
puisse y est de traverser sans trop de
pertes de revenus pour les ménages et
puis en en essayant de s'arranger pour
que les entreprises n'est pas un
problème de trésorerie de cash flow
pendant cette période de confinement
donc si on reste dans un choc limité
avec deux mois et 82 progressivement
reprendre une activité normale je ne dis
pas qu'on va revenir au même niveau
d'emploi exactement je vous dis pas que
certaines entreprises ne vont pas avoir
des difficultés et peut-être même
faillite mais au moins on aura amorti le
choc beaucoup évidemment si ça dure plus
longtemps et dans certains secteurs
comme le tourisme navigation la
restauration ça va être un peu plus
compliqué donc pour bien comprendre les
mesures de soutien à la fois aux
entreprises et aux salariés des
différents gouvernements et la france en
particulier peuvent permettre
d'augmenter les chances à toutes ces
personnes de garder leur emploi et à
toutes ces entreprises au fond de
reconnecter avec une activité à peu près
normale après la craie absolument ici si
on prend le secteur de la construction
par exemple non il n'y a pas de raison
qu après la crise arrêtez commandes de
construction qui sont en général très
longs gants s'arrête et comme les
employés auront été au chômage partiel
ça veut dire toujours dans l'entreprise
et que celles ci ont pour eux ont pu
bénéficier de reports de taxes de
charges de crédit bancaire de garantie
d'état en théorie elles sont capables de
redémarrer à des doses mais non en
pratique quand même on va pas redémarré
exactement la même façon comme vous
savez on va devoir mettre en place et
dans les entreprises parfois ça va être
compliqué des règles de distanciation
sociales deviennent donc ça ça veut dire
des équipes peut-être moins grande ça
veut dire un poème pour la cantine de
l'entreprise ça veut dire des questions
sur elle et le transport en commun donc
il ya quand même des chances qu'on
repart pas enlever comme on dit souvent
mais plutôt en ut très progressivement
et puis certains secteurs qui ont été
confinés et et ça pour le coup ça peut
poser un des vraies questions sur la
soul la viabilité de ces secteurs alors
parlez nous de cette reprise vous nous
dites un hub ça veut dire que en gros
après le déconfinement l'économie va pas
repartir qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous
dire sur les comportements à l'est des
consommateurs pour commencer on va pas
se remettre à consommer à gogo après non
je pense que vous lui avez raison en
fait il ya deux il ya toujours ya deux
effet on peut observer pour la
consommation le premier c'est tout ne va
pas rouvrir dans les mêmes conditions
qu'avant
vous avez
par exemple tous les petits magasins de
votre quartier toutes les règles de
distanciation social ça va j'ai des
sujets et puis à l'autre extrémité du
spectre les grands centres commerciaux
par exemple
qu'il ya certains pays où les grands
centres commerciaux de plus de 800
mètres carrés ne sont pas autorisés à la
réouverture
donc vous avez enfin et puis tant qu'on
n'aura pas trouvé de traitement ou de
vaccins vous et moi on aura peut-être
moins lui de prendre à métro bondé
traverser paris allait trouver la petite
bojic d'oublier certains disent que la
consommation ne pourra reprendre qu'à
noël et qu'il faut qu'un choc comme noël
pour que les gens au fond ait envie de
consommer à nouveau et que d'ici là le
traumatisme de la crise et du virus va
affecter nos comportements alors à mon
sens il ya deux il ya des choses
effectivement l'anxiété qu'on fait avoir
on est triste parce qu'on ne connaît pas
très bien
inciter les personnes à être resté plus
chez elle clairement à prendre un avion
pour partir en vacances à être un peu
plus compliqué surtout dans des pays où
on sait pas nécessairement sida le virus
a été maîtrisée ou pas donc il ya tout
cet aspect là et et si on pense qu'on va
pas revenir à une situation à peu près
normale avec un traitement avant 2021
oui il ya des chances que la
consommation ne soit pas et les prix
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer sur le
pré les prix quand ya plus d'offres et
qui a plus de demande les prix comment
il repartit s'effondre with or not
alors les prix c'est c'est peut-être une
des questions les plus difficiles à
appréhender et je pense que on peut la
regarder de façon la première c'est si
vous regardez en global en fait avec
toutes les mesures de l'état on a à peu
près tenu les capacités de production il
n'y a pas trop de pertes on va on va
supposer ni en entreprise ni en emploi
est en revanche on a une consommation
qui est moins élevé qu'avant mais si on
a moins de consommation et autant de
production il n'ya pas y avoir un effet
à la baisse sur les prix mais dans
certains secteurs par exemple
l'agriculture si si on voit qu'il ya des
tensions parce qu'il faut des
travailleurs saisonniers pour venir
récolter les fruits les légumes que ces
travailleurs saisonniers sédikh sy de
les faire venir tant qu'on a des
restrictions sur le voyage voilà les
prix peuvent effectivement
quels sont les grands secteurs les plus
pénalisées quels sont les secteurs
gagnants
alors les grands secteurs les plus
pénalisés c'est tout ce qu'ils vont être
affectés par des mesures de confinement
et persistante et bien sûr le voyage
il ya peu de chances que vous preniez un
avion pour les états unis dans les deux
mois qui viennent
et du coup le tourisme et bien sûr tous
qui aboie au tout ce qui nécessite aussi
des rassemblements de beaucoup de
personnes on a parlé des festivals
culturels dans tout ce qui est loisirs
ces créations
culture sont des secteurs qui vont être
a effectivement au filet et à l'autre
bout du spectre on va voir tous les
activités où le numérique va aider un
décollage une expansion elles vont
bénéficier entre guillemets de cette
d'ailleurs ce qui peut être vraiment
intéressant pour essayer à redémarrer
très vite c'est d'équipé en logiciels de
livraison simple toutes les petites
entreprises tous les petits commerces
qu'en fait tu allais pas pensé ou n'ont
pas les capacités de faire et aussi
toutes les zones rurales pour sexe pour
s'assurer justement que ce numérique
puisse aider le maximum d'entreprises et
de peps on va numériser le monde après
la crise alors l'europe l'europe va
intervenir aussi pour relancer
l'économie une fois que l'économie va
repartir une fois qu'on va ressortir de
ce confinement on se souvient des grands
travaux de roosevelt juste après la
crise de 1929
donc quoi il faudrait investir
massivement pour relancer et surtout
dessiné l'économie d'après alors ccis et
c'est toujours la question est la plus
difficile mais je pense qu'il ya quand
même trois secteurs qui sont très
intéressants à l'appoint pour
accompagner voire accélérer la reprise
et pour dessiner comme vous dites les
contours du monde de demain le premier
c'est le numérique le numérique peut
être le lien entre tous est un
accélérateur de beaucoup de choses donc
on peut penser à équipées en numérique
tous les territoires ruraux pour
s'assurer que les personnes ont accès à
l'éducation à la santé aussi avec l'été
ou consultation pour permettre aux
entreprises de dead plus intelligente
pour avoir des outils de prévention
santé aussi plus malin avec
l'intelligence artificielle et surtout
surtout pour faire des grilles de
distribution d'énergie qui optimise
entre la production et la consommation
et ça c'est clé pour le déploiement des
énergies renouvelables et ça c'est mon
deuxième point je pense le deuxième
champ très intéressant c'est s'assurer
que cette triste quand on va investir
dans une infrastructure ça va être des
infrastructures vertes et respectueuse
de l'environnement pourquoi parce que
ces investissements sont lourds il met
des années à se mettre en place on les
fait tous les cinq dix ou quinze ans
donc il faut vraiment content où va
effet le dernier point c'est la santé
vous pouvez nous dessiner comme ça
concrètement en quelques mots cette
économie et ce monde de demain d'ici à
les deux cinq dix ans on produira plus
près on mangera mieux et on bougera - on
se déplacera - c'est ça l'idée je suis
pas sûr il ya quelque chose qui est
important dans ce que vous dites et je
pense que plus on va rester dans une
période de confinement va être important
la pandémie va être toujours quelque
part dans le décor donc on fait tant
qu'on a maintenant plus la période pour
avoir un traitement avec sa longue plus
à modifier nos comportements de cessieu
parce que c'est votre corps le bien ses
mémoires et ça ça nous impacte forcément
en revanche si on arrive à un traitement
je pense qu'on va repartir assez ri et
l'endettement sûr qu'il a pesé cet
endettement colossal des états on est à
115% du pib en france sur les
générations futures et a31 moyens en
fait
de gérer cet endettement le premier
c'est augmenter les impôts mais ces
dépenses auraient franchement augmenter
les impôts je pense qu'on est on est on
est très élevé il ya une chose sur les
impôts qui part importante c'est de
s'assurer que il soit ils contribuent à
une certaine égalité une certaine
justice et le sentiment que tout le
monde participe à l'effort de
reconstruction
ensuite il ya l'inflation on en parlait
tout à l'heure à court terme on n'en
voit pas beaucoup mais à moyen terme si
on voit baisser les capacités de
production elle parodie et ça en fait
c'est une espèce de taxes qui favorise
les emprunteurs dont dépend des prêteurs
mais qui est plutôt moins douloureuses
on a fait beaucoup dans les années 70
la dernière chose et je pense qu'il faut
être assez transparent et clair là
dessus c'est une partie de ses dettes va
rester sur le bilan des banques
centrales et c'est aussi comme ça que
sera ce support sap qu'avez vous appris
de la gestion de cette crise qui va nous
servir qui devra nous servir pour après
alors là la chose la plus importante des
deux choses répond - qui sont
extrêmement importantes la première
c'est
la façon dont on regarde les risques
c'est très très important de les
intégrer beaucoup plus dans notre
quotidien parce qu'on en aura d'autres y
aura d'autres accidents y aura des
accidents climatiques y aura d'autres
accidents de santé donc pas regarder
juste le climat où luce la santé ou
juste la finance mais à voir je pense
qu'on en manque une organisation qui
fait le lien entre tous est capable de
faire des scénarios de risque et
d'alerté de façon suffisamment ford en
impliquant la société en étant
redevables devant le parlement c'est
super impôts et puis la deuxième chose
qu'on a pris presque rien de pourpre en
place le contact humain on va là
numérique mais franchement l'aspect
social et d'ailleurs les négociations
c'est ce qu'a fait des grandes religions
c'est hyper
merci infiniment merci laurence boone
d'avoir accepté cet entretien à distance
et à bientôt j'espère en face à face en
chair et en os le pivot tunisien
[Musique]